[Music]  a new lawsuit alleges travel companies  like expedia  orbits and travelocity withheld millions  of dollars in potential state tax  revenue  according to the lawsuit online travel  companies contract with hotels for the  right to purchase rooms at discounted  rates  according to court paperwork the  companies then sell those rooms at a  higher rate  but according to the suit the companies  then pay tax on the lower rate  an attorney work in the case tells us  what that means  different camera municipal and state  entities  that benefit the people who  live here did not get this  revenue that they were entitled to 22  different companies are named as  defendants the co-attorney who filed the  lawsuit says the travel companies have  yet to be served